you've been involved in some controversy
and I think I need to address this okay
in a special that you did use in the
special that you did you said made a
joke and you said let's build a wall
around Louisiana right and that made
people some people very unhappy
specifically the people that live in
Louisiana is there anything you'd like
to say about this I mean yeah like it
was a joke I got a lot of hate mail you
got a lot of anger internet they were
like I think I wake up and I opened my
phone like the day the special came that
come out and camp came out came out so
done come out done come out
I opened Twitter and I sent it a saint
on the phone
and it says if you ever break down in
Louisiana spelled BR a ke like you
better hope we don't find you and I'm
like what did I do and I was like oh
yeah I remember that no said a quick
joke yeah joke and then I would get
messages of support where people were
like hey man I live in Louisiana
I'm not mad because I was watching a
comedy show I know this wasn't a stump
speech you're not running for Congress
you know and I was like yeah like so
it's not a big deal but then people be
like no you you cross the line with that
joke about building a wall I'm like do
you understand what time we're living in
here like you understand the context
like our current administration wants to
build a wall to keep people out from
like quote [ __ ] countries I'm just
saying let's put a wall around a
[ __ ] State
[Applause]
well I'm glad we brought it up and you
cleared everything up
disgraceful is available on Netflix
tickets are on sale now to see Tom live
in New Orleans on September 29 that Tom
Segura calm well we won't be seeing you
again
you